-Guys, you all know
how to play charades.
Each player gets a turn, giving
silent clues to their teammate,
30 seconds on the clock
per turn.
We'll do four rounds,
then the fifth round
is a charades showdown. Wow.
-That's so exciting.
-Both teams get the same clue
at the same time.
I will go first.
You guys
can all take your seats.
Emily, you're sitting over here.
-Team Jimmy.
-Yeah, this will be fun.
Here we go, pal.
We can do this.
[ Breathes deeply ]
-We got this.
-What number do we want,
you guys?
-Five!
-Okay, sir.
[ Laughter ]
"Five!"
Mm.
-Song.
-Yes, okay, good.
Okay, here -- yeah.
-Okay, four words.
One -- first word.
Jimmy, you.
You -- I.
I -- okay.
[ Chuckles ]
Fourth word.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, no.
Uh, snaggletooth, um...
"I am the walrus"!
-Yes!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
You feel this?
We are gonna win.
I knew -- I knew it.
I knew it!
And I knew it, and I knew it,
knew it, knew it!
[ Laughs ]
Yes!
Yes, sir, man!
Whoo! Whoo!
-You got one point.
-Well, yes, just one,
but still, I feel like
I really got a good one.
-Feels like
an outsized reaction.
[ Audience shouting ]
-"Five!"
[ Shouting continues ]
-I'm gonna go with that,
I'm gonna go with that.
-Hmm.
-Ah.
-All this confidence.
-Yeah, I can tell.
-Yeah, he's too confident,
right?
Yeah, I don't like it, either.
-Movie.
-Good ol' hand-cranked film.
[ Laughter ]
-Three words.
-Mm-hmm.
-Second word.
[ Laughter ]
Horse.
"The Horse Whisperer."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I'm on the board!
-Really?
-Sometimes you have to act
like you've been there, Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, really?
What other movie could it be?
"The horse something."
Now, I'm like, get the --
"The Horse Doctor," yeah.
-"Charlie Horse McGee"?
You've never heard of that film?
-That was a good one.
-Great movie.
-"Charlie Horse McGee" was good.
-Is this me?
-This is you, pal.
Let's go.
-All right, what number?
[ Audience shouting ]
All right.
-We got it, pards.
-All right.
[ Clears throat ]
-Love it, the confidence.
Yes.
-All right.
-Love this.
Yeah, it's a movie.
Two words.
First word.
[ Laughter ]
Duck.
Quack -- the goose,
wings, chicken.
"Chicken Run."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Okay, okay.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
Yeah, I've been there
a couple times, man.
-Apparently.
That's good to know.
[ Audience shouting ]
I'm hearing 4.
[ Laughter ]
Ooh, they're magnetized.
-Yes.
-Yeah, their fancy.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, boy.
[ Laughter ]
-Ha ha.
-He's acting, he's acting.
He's acting.
-Okay.
-He's acting.
He knows this.
-He's faking his -- He's faking
his own teammate out.
-It's a book.
And a movie.
Okay.
-Wow, wow, wow.
-Four words.
First word.
Short.
It, the, a.
Fourth word.
Time.
A -- Okay.
A -- "A Wrinkle in Time."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
We'll do it.
-I didn't know where
I was going with "wrinkle."
-Wow! Wow!
Okay, here's what's up.
Now Emily and John are going
to be up here giving the clues.
And you'll be giving the same
clue at the same time, okay?
And whoever gets it first, wins.
So you'll guess and I'll guess.
-Oh, my God.
-You two, please, our guests.
Yeah.
-All right.
-Come on, we can do this, pal.
-You...
-No, no, no, no, no.
Audience's choice, audience's --
-Seven!
-Seven.
-That was clearest call I heard.
-That was really clear.
-Whoo!
-Oh, my -- [ Laughs ]
Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
-Okay, yes.
Song.
-Song. Oh.
-Three words.
-First word.
-The first word, heart --
-Swimming, drowning, drinking.
-Heart, love.
-"Drunk in Love."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I went the other way.
I went the other way.
-Oh!
Laughing ]
That was fantas--
-We all did it!
-We're all winners!
-Except you guys won.
-Jon Hamm, Emily Ratajkowski.
The champions right here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Tariq Trotter.